fortsetzung folgt das sind die besten
film vom schweizer fernsehen
mit menschen auf dem höhepunkt
persönliches schicksal
und diese vorträge vom alltag
ihre grenze und
berufsschichten mit dass im leben und
gangsterfilms winter
wird zum zwei ganz verschiedene schlaue
mit der gemeinsamen mission
topmodel sarina arnold und die
pensioniert die rocking brigit winkel
seine helfer zieht kirgistan kind womit
rallye kiefer gaumenspalte geboren
worden sind
wie zum beispiel marine kreis steinburg
hütt fünf jahre nach der operation
[Musik]
eine geschichte worden
da sich fortsetzung folgt
[Musik]
es ist blitze welt vor der inszenierte
schönheit nocerino arnold schon seit
fast 20 jahren ihres geld drin verdient
mit 4 3 ski show forschte legende unter
schweizer morgens keine andere hat sich
so lange im business zu behaupten
das ist die schöne fassade aber dahinter
finden wie die sarina arnold nur ganz
andere geschichte ihre tochter vieles
ist noch mit einer schwere gesichts welt
kommen er liebte kiefer gaumenspalte und
der persönliche schicksalsschlag der in
anholt motiviert so auch andere
betroffene hinterher gestand sie machen
das zwei mal mit der ärztin bringt
winkel und der autorin helen stellt
fischer hat dir beide verschiedene
frauen verfügt auf ihre mission
begleitet entstanden ist fehlen voller
hoffen
[Musik]
das ist phillies die tochter von sarina
arnold auf diesen bildern ist phillies
ein jahr alt und bereits operiert mit
den fotos nach der geburt ist sarina
arnold zurückhaltend sie sind ihr zu
privat
sarina arnold erfuhr im siebten monat
der schwangerschaft dass mit ihrem kind
etwas nicht in ordnung war ein schock
für sie und ihren mann rafael
phillies hatte eine schwere lippen
kiefer gaumenspalte
das pflaster zwischen nase und mund den
der die haut vor der operation
heute sieht man verließ fast nichts mehr
an die operation ist gut gelungen der
schrecken des basierten gesichts
verflogen wie ein böser traum
ja ich einfach ja die höchsten wellen
es kostet ihn herum trifft das jetzt
nicht
locker und einfach viel
bringt nur geburtsvorbereitungskurs
ist
ja klar
unter dem umstand
dass man sie auch zu sagen
mag den hang stand man muss das leben
hat er so ist und durchaus
nicht so
schlicht ist sehr gut lesbar und
die erinnerungen sind noch lebendig
schon bald fliegt sarina deshalb ins
ferne kirgistan um kindern mit demselben
geburtsfehler zu helfen
kirgistan das land an der großen
seidenstraße
[Musik]
er haben sind seine gebirge
atemberaubend die natur
man nennt es auch die schweiz
zentralasiens
[Musik]
doch in der muslimischen berg republik
türmen sich die probleme
sie ist bitterarm korrupt und politisch
instabil
seit kirgistan 1991 selbstständig wurde
geht alles bergab seither fließt kein
geld mehr aus moskau viele sind
arbeitslos und ein drittel der
bevölkerung lebt unter der armutsgrenze
worunter vor allem auch die kinder
leiden
in der hauptstadt bischkek im nationalen
kinderspital hat die schweizer stiftung
zuversicht für kinder ein
behandlungszentrum für kinder mit lippen
kiefer gaumenspalten eingerichtet
sarina arnold ist neue botschafterin der
stiftung und besucht kirgistan zum
ersten mal
zusammen mit der stiftungsrätin und
ärztin brigit winkler
[Musik]
sarina ist nur wenige tage da und will
möglichst viel sehen von spittaler und
seinen kleinen patienten
brigit die hier alle und jeden kennt
wird sie einführen
[Musik]
zurzeit sind ausländische ärzte in
spittal und kinder zu operieren das hat
sich herumgesprochen
im kalten spital gang herrscht seit
stunden ein gedränge das ärzte team kann
unmöglich alle berücksichtigen über 100
kinder mit gesichts fehlbildungen wird
das team an diesem tag die gutachten
für dieses projekt sehr sehr viele bb
wochen
ist die operation jetzt eigentlich
[Musik]
an diesem ersten morgen lernen wir den
sechs monate alten kairat kenne
die ergebnisse vorstellen
ähnlich sah phillies aus salinas tochter
[Musik]
es ist praktisch kein
nasensteg hier
[Musik]
so schwere spalten können die kirgisen
derzeit gar nicht oder nur unvollständig
operieren
warum sind sie gerade jetzt nach
bischkek ins spital gekommen
die ärzte sagten die spalte sehr
kompliziert wir sollten zu den
spezialisten gehen
heirat hat ein riesen glück die
spezialisten werden ihm zu einem neuen
schönen gesicht verhelfen
[Musik]
sarina arnold wird bald hautnah
miterleben wie heirat die spalte
operativ geschlossen wird
am nächsten morgen fahren wir zu den
eltern von karat ins hinterland
vielerorts sind kirgistan wurde
jahrzehntelang uran abgebaut ohne die
radioaktiven abfälle richtig zu
entsorgen dies ist ein vermuteter grund
weshalb in kirgistan
überdurchschnittlich viele kinder mit
einer lippen kiefer gaumenspalte geboren
werden doch bewiesen ist nichts die
ursachen für eine fehlbildung sind
komplex auch mangelernährung genetische
defekte oder infektionen während der
schwangerschaft sind faktoren
die eltern von kyra taten uns zu sich
ins dorf eingeladen früher arbeiteten
hier alle in einem holz betrieb doch der
ist heute stillgelegt
nach der heirat suchte nadja uhl und
format arbeit in moskau doch dann kam
der bub zur welt und sie kehrten zu
ihrer familie zurück ihren job hatten
sie verloren und eine operation in
moskau konnten sie sich nicht leisten
fließendes wasser gibt es im haus nicht
der 30 jährige oma ist wie die meisten
arbeitslos oder in der hauptstadt
bischkek bessere aussichten hätte ist
ungewiss hier besitzt er wenigstens
einen eigenen boden und betreibt etwas
landwirtschaft
zudem hoffen er und seine frau auf bed
and breakfast touristen natur pur haben
sie genug doch die instabile politische
lage schreckt alle ab
die gesichts fehlbildung ihres sohnes
traf sie wie ein blitz aus heiterem
himmel
sagt euch die ärzte in moskau deshalb
hat er die spalte
sie sagten eine infektion
eine krankheit
die ging
war es als ihren sohn zum ersten mal
sahen
ich hatte einen schock ich hatte noch
nie ein solches kind gesehen
nicht vorbereitet
heirats eltern leben zusammen mit ihrer
großfamilie
alle nehmen anteil an ihrem schicksal
jetzt freuen sie sich dass ausländische
chirurgen kairat bald operieren
[Musik]
bloß etwas angst haben sie schon und
werden sie ihn mit einem neuen gesicht
auch wiedererkennen
zurück im kinderspital in der hauptstadt
bischkek
an diesem morgen tritt kairat mit seinen
eltern ins krankenhaus ein
[Musik]
das krankenzimmer hat sieben becken weil
das geld für das personal fehlt werden
alle kinder von der mutter oder
großmutter betreut die hier mit ihnen im
selben bett übernachten
auch at t gold bleibt die ganze zeit bei
ihrem sohn
oder macht
und sich so schnell geht's da später
oder und heinz überhaupt die chance ob
er fahren
als aushängeschild der stiftung wird die
prominente sarina im spital ständig
fotografiert
[Musik]
worin besteht
als botschafterin
das alles verändert hat dass das alles
läuft da
sie werde dafür zähle gar nicht die
schweiz verliert ist so dass ich mal was
man da alles sitzen in dem von der wenig
erfahrung
eben von der stiftung zuversicht für
kinder finanzierten operationssaal
treffen die ärzte die letzten
vorbereitungen
heirats große stunde ist gekommen die
anstehende operation wird sein leben
verändern
auf diesen moment hat die familie seit
seiner geburt sehnlichst gewartet mutter
ag konnte vor aufregung die ganze nacht
nicht schlafen
die operation ist kompliziert und david
zweieinhalb stunden
der über 70 jährige professor erich
hauser operiert an diesem tag fünf
kinder mit schweren spalten regiert war
vollblut chirurgin und liebt es hier
gelegentlich noch zu assistieren
wir oldies sagt professor hausnamen sind
ein eingespieltes team und die erfahrung
zähle bei diesen operationen mehr als
jugendlicher schnelligkeit
insgesamt hat der professor in der
letzten sechs jahren mit seinem team
über 700 kinder operiert noch nie waren
die bedingungen so gut wie jetzt im
alten operationssaal wackelten die
stühle und das licht will immer wieder
aus
am schluss traut sich auch sarina hinein
sie war noch nie bei einer operation
dabei es braucht einige überwindung
[Musik]
die operation verlief wunschgemäß heirat
hat alles gut überstanden
beim nächsten einsatz wird das team dann
seinen gaumen verschließen
sie sind so schön gemacht und ich meine
frau ist meine tochter und frau nicht
mehr zur lage und mit dr
[Musik]
gleich nach der operation über gibt der
alles dies ist in kleinen der mutter
[Musik]
heirat ist noch offen
auch jetzt muss sich die mutter selbst
um ihn kümmern keine krankenschwester
ist da um zu helfen
dafür steht kai maaz großmutter ihr bei
[Musik]
heirat weint immer zu als er aus der
narkose langsam wieder erwacht
[Musik]
alkohol versucht ihren sohn auf
kirgisischer weise zu beruhigen
[Musik]
meine tochter hat nach der operation
auch viel geweint aber
[Musik]
wir sind den ärzten so dankbar
mögen sie gesund bleiben
[Musik]
sarina muss all die neuen eindrücke
verdauen bei kirgisischen mit konfitüre
gar manches läuft hier anders als sarina
es aus der schweiz kennt
wald fährt sie nach hause der aufenthalt
war nur kurz aber dafür umso intensiver
wenig später geht es schon viel besser
und am schluss ihres besuchs im
kinderspital sarina eines ganz genau
[Applaus]
richtig
für sarina ist ist ein abschied von
kirgistan
bald wird sie wieder ihre tochter in die
arme schließen können
[Musik]
es sind viele vergangene sieht einen
rufnamen der inhalt ist immer noch am
ortler und ist mit ihrem engagement für
kirche standards gesetzt das gar nicht
jeder folgen sobald sie da mal kurze
pause hat
satz mit streamen von ihnen besetzte
kloster und abflugverfahren
dopings keine sie war einmal und lächelt
und dann verschwinden du bist also immer
nur botschafterin ja ich bin immer ein
botschafter ins zweiten mal durex mit
ins projekt wie größe
also wir sind nach wie vor drehen
sich alle miteinander vor dem
wiedersehen
warum ist das immer so wichtig spiele zu
haupt hochwertig seien betroffen und
darum ist das für mich das passte
einfach und ich weiß was ich rede ich
jetzt bereit
sarina arnold wird ersetzt oder
vierbeiner hundedame mit dem namen immer
die ist vielleicht weniger hübsch aus
carina für pflegeleichte mit ihrem hohen
zu viel braucht auf jeden fall kein
hairstylist
so sehr der zentrale wert ist
ja ich finde ich
wenn ich so schön humor wieder rund
boden der tatsachen zurück jetzt beginne
tochter faye ist ich suche hinaus thema
aber ganz andere nach der geburt hinaus
erstmals
die ja die ganze anspannung nicht schon
vor der geburt wo man hat und den ich
weiß nicht welche
brille und es
ist so groß und
ich kann immer mehr und immer
komisch wie es geht ja verschiedene es
geht ja noch liebt den bäumen
ist und sand aus dem projekt das in
hannover gesehen und es ist
ja und dann die ganze anspannung nach
einer geburt und dann bin ich schon so
so einem brühler moment für fahrer und
den himmel so richtig realisiert ja so
stehen sie hat mir jetzt aber schnell
unterwegs
damals platzte vor der operation das
muskel schon gelernt habe mit einem
dicken wirtschaft wird muskel sind ja
durchtrennt sozusagen nicht mit
landschaften
und messen wirklich aus dem mega-hit
system haben das in brüssel machen diese
stehen auch die operation ist vom morgen
um halb sieben jetzt die kunden um sich
zu gruseln ist also
telefonieren
eine betreuungsperson mutig betreute
identität und sein herr manfred christ
was läuft aber das ist längst ja
nicht einfach
wenn das hat ja die vier
musikalische das baby was wirklich gut
gesehen hat ihr eintritt reagiert ja ich
habe zum beispiel media also ich bin ja
immer gefragt wurde wie chance und ist
wild und und dann muss sie denn ich war
ja schon wissen dass sie das hebt und
vista media war würde nachfrage und den
heimerfolg ist und wenn es das ist
gesund aber sie hätte ich kaum sport und
so ist ein persönlicher schicksalsschlag
vor dass arena öffentlich wurde mit
einer positiven auswirkung stiftung
zuversicht für kinder erzieht aufgabe
als botschafterin
engagement
mit
dem
rad unterwegs sind sie fertig für ein
mensch ist für mich ganz ein
herzensguter mensch also ich finde was
sie macht eine frau
jahrelang schaffe dem spital und jetzt
wo sie frei machen zurücklehnen kann man
auch risiken einzugehen und so dass sie
nur einen linksfuß
einigkeit und das will ich einfach
deutschland ist so richtig geplant
das arena ihres mode shooting ist nur
lange fertig
[Musik]
ich habe mit ihren abgemacht dass ich
sie und ihre tochter felice später die
heikle jobsuche wir waren benz seinen
rufnamen vor ihrem letzten besuch in
kirgistan a new york wo sie die burg rad
wieder gesehen hat
[Musik]
vorher war aber die zweite hauptperson
vor dem film gut treffe der weg für mich
ist bayern kapital
bleibt die pensioniert die
kinderchirurgie twinkle
danke mal
vom china ist das geschehen
dran namens kirgistan oder so
erschien
blickwinkel ist immer noch engagiert
kreativ
sie hat mit grosser das trend nicht nur
der hauptstadt bischkek operiert werden
können sondern neu auch in einem
behandlungszentrum andere stadt im süden
vom land
das projekt im krieg gestehen dass ich
zum nokia setzt zu einem zentrum in
oschatz das ist so dass die kollegen vor
ort stets
weiterzubilden
vor zwei jahren
in haus versorgt zentrum aufbauen was
ich dass ich gesagt das machen der
patient ist ein werk von roche nach die
strecke wird das geht über
100 meter seit zwölf stunden
klinik kinos schon kennt ist ihr sehr
sehr
viel und ich sie darum eigentlich sehr
gerne
dass man die neuhaus und von einem
zentrum
bilden
ein kollege vom zentralschweizer
fernsehen tele ist winkel und sarina
arnold 4 mio sie begleitet die
zweitgrößte stadt in kirgistan mit
250.000 einwohnern
im bezirk spittal werden gäste aus der
schweiz begrüsst
regiert winkler
und sarina arnold der neue
operationssaal wird eingeweiht
es ist frühjahr 2014
ermöglicht wurde der neue
operationszahlen mit geldern aus der
schweiz
dank der finanziellen hilfe wurde unsere
infrastruktur viel moderne zudem konnten
wir von unseren mediziner kollegen auch
viel lernen was operationstechniken
anbelangt darüber bin ich sehr glücklich
[Musik]
die schweizer stiftung zuversicht für
kinder ist seit zehn jahren aktiv in
kirgistan seit einem jahr werden lippen
kiefer gaumenspalten nun auch in
operiert 200 kindern konnte schon
geholfen werden mit dem neuen
operationssaal verbessern sich die
bedingungen für die medizinische
behandlung deutlich
ich lese chefs gemacht wurde und damals
lag
nun müssen die einheimischen ärzte noch
weiter geschult werden selig dass der
anschluss operativ so gut sie wie man in
europa gleich gut aber dort die heilige
ich wollte dass lothar nach darüber
firma
sie sich
hilfe zur selbsthilfe oder wie die
kirgisen sagen gibt den menschen keine
fische sondern lehre sie fischer
zieht wo sie tätig sind sind sophie
familie so viel kinder selber begleitet
mit operiert wenn das ganze projekt
aktiv situation sie für das kind in
kirchen statt womit sich zwei bilder oft
wild bevor ihr 1000 und wie ich sie also
schock sie das hätten erste
sehr viele
touristen die praxis sehe mit operierten
das team lebe mit politisch unmöglich
also mehr kassen und leben lassen sich
nicht gesellschaftlich daran denkt die
sie versteckt wurde zum teil sind die
erwachsenen mit einer komischen gebracht
das sehr viel
operation
wurde
jedoch parierte sparen ms für die
praktisch geschafft
aber hey lang braucht führt der erste
platz machen dass man die vorbildlich
sagt im rettungsauto operieren wir gute
resultat ort wo es immer noch hinunter
jährige mit sprechstunden
mit so viel engagement
dieses projekt die wie sie das macht und
winkel
was ist ihre motivation waren dazu
bringt das helfe wählen oder was ist
nicht helfen zwei
kilo die auf eine farce machen als ich
otto lag sie nach besonders du ja
natürlich die idee dass man noch immer
bis hilft sinnvoll ist nicht einfach nur
ein paradies
operieren scott parker sondern
wirklich nachhaltig helfen also sie
hatten stand sehr viel aber sind auch
sehr viele wochen ja sehr viel bekommt
ich glaube nicht dass sie haben viel
pracht und nicht auf
[Musik]
mit gott bringt winken ihm so viel
aufgestaut wie früher und sie stand
immer selber im operationssaal aber in
ruhestand treten uns projekt dass racing
team frank aber dem kriege stand sie als
lebenselixier sagt wien kap im abschied
die nächste station ist zürcher
goldküste
dort fällt meile brief wie abgemacht
sarina arnold pier iii
[Musik]
sie wohnt mit ihrer tochter verließ und
ihre mama
wird aber bacher ist große hobby von
sarina
nachmacht
jetzt zieht es oft weg zum kranksein
zweite
[Musik]
display mir betroffen mache durchsucht
der
schlittschuhe
[Musik]
studien des mannes mit
dem doxis4
führer zieht großfamilie yahoo kritik
die tv bossen zur sprache gekommen
sie machen es gab kürzlich einen
oskar sager meister verlängern das ist
noch immer wo es
hin will das hält nicht richtig
schlosser im rheder
aussage ist luft
dass
sie nach
zwei
wochen
wieder
im kindergarten genauso
gemacht so
einfach
dass es nach der korrektur von ralf
kiefer gaumenspalten zusätzliche
operationen braucht ist nicht
außergewöhnlich schließlich verändert
sich das gesicht von marin während dem
wachstum noch stark
dass sie wenn dies nicht geschieht
sondern zwei spielen klar gestellt
und ich denke einen gegenstand muss das
angebot ist premiere damals war wichtig
dass die sache dann aber im einzelfall
so das lied wissen komme ich hinter
dollar bringen oder sie informiert sind
dass das ist
ganz wichtig ist
also
ist das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wichtigste
so
richtig schön
begleitet
[Applaus]
und jetzt
das
[Musik]
die nun vierköpfige familie ist vor drei
jahren umgezogen da der vater hier
immerhin eine chance auf
gelegenheitsjobs hat
das leben der ganzen familie hat sich
zum besseren gewendet zeit kehrt durch
die unterstützung aus der schweiz ein
neues gesicht bekommen hat
als kind mit einer fehlbildung auf die
welt gekommen ist habe ich aufgehört zu
leben erst nach seiner operation hat
sich das geändert und ich hätte wieder
lebendig
[Musik]
es auch nichts dass ich nicht wie
vorgeschrieben
und bringe mich so bekannt und ich hoffe
ja
[Musik]
heirat ein gesunder junge voller
lebensenergie
[Musik]
vergessen ist die zeit als eine spalte
im gesicht von karat der ganzen familie
große sorgen bereitete mit dem wissen
dass es den vierjährigen gut geht kann
sich auch sarina arnold einfacher
verabschieden
die letzte spiel da drauf und kratsch
emotionale momente für die ich nicht nur
begeistert so nicht getroffen also und
herzlicher abgestellter burg wo
überhaupt nicht
[Musik]
mehr wenn sie die finanziellen
unterstützer
einer fahrt über also
da unterstützen persönliche kontakte und
da weiß ich muss gar donnergott bucher
und die schlitten raus
[Gelächter]
und ich arbeite auch
für dich selbst wenn du jetzt auch das
engagement zog das gefühl dass du diese
engagement unterschied macht jetzt in
trier gestorben ja ich hoffe
ich treffe so
dass ich heuer erlebnis ab und trag ich
habe maschine nicht operiert was rollt
da für ronny rogawska machen dass man
die operation auch finanzieren also
durch die friedensbotschaft genau
engagieren sich für kinder aus
[Musik]
birne psychokrieg gestartet sarina
arnold gesehen dass es gut
verständlich ist darum geht's wieder von
ihrem glück was ein buch
[Musik]
nächste woche treffen oder bekannteste
berg stiko für die schmidts der ueli
steck vor sieben jahren beinahe zwei
stunden dass sie eine 40 minuten eiger
nordwand beruf grant und zum schnellsten
amberg wurde ein höhepunkt in ihrer
karriere
sie denn hätte uli steckte schlag
erlebte ist am everest von sherpas
attackiert wurde und hat angst um das
leben hat anna ist eine extrem gute
kletterer turnier geschafft hat aber
alle glauben im dorf und zum rekorder
michael hätten andere brauchen war sind
die rückschlag mit dem urin steckt macht
fortsetzung folgt in einer woche